I know it's a very basic way.
I mean we've been talking about
good and evil since the time of uh,
the men were able and women were able to,
you know,
write and write and philosophize
and though, but I don't know,
it just seems to me lately like I've
see it feels to me like evil and good is
actually a force that we're
struggling with. And I know there's,
I know like some people would
say that's kind of a, you know,
a primitive way of thinking,
but I do kind of feel like, uh,
it actually is a very,
a real tangible thing.
And that,
what makes you think this
look your personal feelings?
Is it based on like your intuition?
Like what is it
I, yeah, it's intuition. It's
like a vibe. It's like a,
it's just like a,
maybe because I'm showing up at church
and kind of like searching a little bit.
Myself and I,
I am very much about good people doing
good things and I'm just been kind of
conscious of it. But then there's
always like these, this rise of evil,
they like comes up like all of
a sudden white supremacists are,
these riots are these horrible things
against people in different parts of the
world. And it's, it seems like
it's this ongoing struggle
look almost like why hasn't caught up
yet to the way you look at the world,
the way a lot of people look at the world.
Yeah.
It's a lot of people look at the
world like, like if Tom Papa,
if you were in charge and if you had to
push all the buttons that would sort of
decide how people behaved,
that was a possible thing.
Of course you'd have one of the first
thing you do is eliminate all the violence
and all the horrors of the world.
Yeah.
And then also, I'm sorry to cut
you off, but you also see the,
all those horrors are done
by these men and stuff.
Who when you sit in like kind of analyze
them and they've been the victims of a
lot of things and there's like genetic
victimization and social and it's like,
so where's that coming from?
Why are these,
this kid that could have been okay ends
up in this life of crime and ends up
murdering somebody and
where's that coming from?
Is this just a genetic mutation or is
there like a force of good and evil?
I think we're still, we're still
dealing with the echoes of the past.
That's what I really firmly believe.
And I think also the way maybe you and
I are having this conversation the way a
lot of people are having these
conversations today, just like us,
like basically the same sort of rational
people sitting around with no agenda
going, why does this exist? Why, why
does all the horrors of life, why,
why is all this injustice? Why is
that there? I think this is, uh,
we haven't been here that long.
I just really think that that's real
and I think we need to absorb that much
better.
Or our time spent in modern civilization
versus the time of life on earth is a
joke.
The time on life,
on earth and in relationship to the
time of the universe is a joke, right?
The numbers are insane. We
can't understand that. We,
we were monkeys just a couple
of weeks ago. Right. Well,
the bit that I have my act about the
United States being founded in 1776 that's
three people ago. Lindsey, behind her,
that's three people go really is. Yeah.
That's nothing.
So three people go,
people were these creatures that,
uh,
had to make fire to stay warm.
They didn't have electricity,
they didn't have engines. Yeah.
They made boats at a trees and they use
the wind to drift across the ocean while
staring at the stars with a fucking
gigantic harp looking thing. Right?
What was the thing?
A sextant that thing that they use to
figure out where the other ones are.
So he had a trust that these motherfuckers
had mapped out the universe. Well,
he could make it across the ocean.
And a lot of people died of scurvy along
the way. Like, fuck man, that's crazy.
Not long ago.
So God damned recently
when I was listening to Dan
Carlin's hardcore history,
one of the best podcasts ever of you,
I don't know if you're so good,
but he has this thing on the mon goals
called the wrath of the cons and what
freaked me out is not just how crazy
that world was back then and what
unbelievable damage and destruction
the Mongols created and how they just
conquered empires just
moved across the world,
killed millions and millions of people,
but it was really fucked up was I think
Google this to make sure I'm not wrong.
I think that was only like 1200 BC.
I don't think that was that long
ago. Right. That's really recent.
That's really racist.
I think Gingiss Kahn died in the
1200 to five remember correctly?
508 not BC. A d. Oh, did I
say BC? I actually met a date.
I said BC, but it really did mean
a DJ in the more recent 800 years.
I'm a little stone if I'd
have made it tomorrow,
but that 1200 well 1,260 would still
be still be pretty fucking recent,
but 1,208 d, which is what I
meant to say was so recent. Yes.
That's just not that long
ago. Yeah, that's the,
we're starting to make wine and
sour dough, right? Ish. Other way,
other way.
92 seven nine two 792 years ago a guy
killed 50 million people during his
lifetime with his actions. Right. They
changed the carbon footprint of the world.
I mean they, they oid I mean they, they,
so then you're saying it's more right?
I was right.
You're saying it's more surprising that
we're doing this kind of stuff and that
we have electric cars and the medicine
and all this other kind of like,
it's more surprising that we're doing
that than it is that people are running
around killing each other.
Well, Nazi Germany too.
That was 1940s it's crazy.
That's maybe crazier than anything.
You know,
if you and Carla and has
some great stuff on that too.
And the history of World War One and
World War II. But if you're, you're,
you're watching a documentary on that and,
and you watching those people move around,
especially the one that you showed me,
Jamie, that's been digitally remastered.
When you see it in color, is that Ken?
Is it Ken Burns it to
that? Yeah, I think so.
They digitally remastered some footage
from World War One and you get to watch
these people move around, look
in real time, you realize like,
oh these are just people.
They're just like you. I know.
And this is like a hundred years ago,
hundred years ago were involved in this
crazy ass war and then a few years later
involved another crazy ass war.
So why can't we figure it out dude?
He goes, how long he was
present? I don't know. I think,
I think it used to be the only
way that people got by, I think.
I think from going from
small groups of people,
which like in the small groups of people,
they would have interpersonal conflicts.
They would have fights
with members in the tribe,
but they would sort it out and there
would probably be some sort of rule that
they would all try to live by.
But then they would get invaded by
people that didn't have anything.
And then when looking for your stuff and
they came over the top of the hill and
they killed and they raped and they,
they stole women and they just
did that for a long ass time. Man.
They did that for a long ass time.
This was the history
of the steps like that.
Dan Carlin maps out in this wrath of
Khan thing makes you go, Jesus, Chris,
imagine being born then Nanchang just
imagine how crazy that me being a baby at
seeing arrows flying around and if
people could open to people were lighting
people on fire and launching them
onto roofs with catapults, right?
This is the footage for World War One.
So look how they digitally
remastered it and
yeah, Peter Jackson is taking a
movie, I believe, or a documentary.
That's the craziest thing.
When you look at history and you think,
well that was then it's like no, they're
just us. Just happened to be there.
Really no different than you and
dude, we haven't been here this
long. We haven't been here this long.
This is the thing like
people that looked like this,
that awaring like uniforms
and that are you know,
have like decent stuff, nice wheels to
their wagons, all that kind of shit.
That's real recent man.
No,
I know it's reached in his
fuck and there's been a
bunch of different ways that
people have done it,
you know?
But even if he go back to like the
Egyptians but isn't it the act of like,
okay so we know like that guy
let his house on fire. Yeah,
we know that is a just instinctually we
know and have known during even all of
us this history, we've known that that
is evil like right. You know what I mean?
Like it's insanely selfish.
It's not like we went from having to
like eat each other and that we're trying
to get our act together. You
know what I mean? There is a,
we all know that that is such a evil,
evil thing.
I think it exists.
I think we have to fight it.
It is evil, but it's ego
that's causing that. Right?
That guy didn't want to go to jail.
It didn't want to shoot himself,
didn't want to kill himself
and didn't want to go to jail.
So he decided he was going to kill a
bunch of people to make up a story.
He had a plot in his plows to
save himself. All right. You know,
and that's when people get trapped in a
situation where they're allowed to make
decisions and they're allowed to,
you know,
if not allowed to.
But if they choose to make decisions and
those decisions are horrific and then
they have to somehow or another justify
those decisions cause they never look at
their own behavior.
They always judge other people.
And this is a pattern
that people fall into,
whether it was looking for other
people to always be wrong, right?
And they never grow.
And so like a guy like that,
if he was so psychotic that
he could kill somebody.
And then he has this decision to make.
This decision is to kill the wife and
the kids still the keys just like always
gotta be right. You know what I'm
saying? Like he's always, he's got an e,
he's trying to cover his tracks,
he's trying to lie always like this
is the type of person that could do
something like that horrific pattern or
thought and it might have been triggered
by the murder itself. So it's just a
chemical flipping his brain that says,
now I can kill people.
Like he hasn't done it his whole life
and he's just going into the subway and
getting a sandwich with all the stuff on
it and just be like watching the Monday
night football.
And then the next week he's like,
something flips in his brain
is like, no, now I can kill.
I don't think it's a little
painful that I know and love.
I think in a fit of rage, in a fit
of rage, he does something horrific.
And then I think he's one of those
people that tries to justify his actions.
So it just totally tries to figure
out a way where he can justify it,
that they're, they're going to be in hell
anyway cause the guy's dead. You know,
they'd,
they'd probably
deep he could. You think we're crazy
man. They come up with justification.
We came from the side, like
we said before, this is an
Italian dude like us. Right?
But he could've also,
we don't know if he's medicated.
Do we know that it's a
big warning in chemistry.
We don't know what he was doing.
You know what I mean?
He could have been on
something which, uh, you know,
makes people do horrific things. Do
you think, do you believe in Karma?
I think for sure that when
you put energy out there,
it affects things around you in terms
of the way people interact with you.
And that in turn affects the way they
will interact with other people as well.
And I think there's like,
there's, there's a certain amount,
there's an energy you put out,
you could call it that,
but that makes it sound like you got a
crystal in your pocket, right? Not really.
Energy is real. It's like energy is
a real thing. There is a real right.
If I was, if I was a murderer
and came and sat in here,
there'd be a different vibe than what
you're feeling from me. Yeah, for sure.
You know what I mean? For sure.
Yeah. A chronic masturbator well,
it's also people that are off and then
struggling with the fact that they've
done something awful. Right.
There's like an energy to that.
It's like a constantly being on
edge energy every and punishment.
That's still CFC. Yeah. I never
read that. Oh, you should read it.
It's so he kills someone
and this is the east caring.
It's the Gill greatest description of
the guilt. Just carrying that thing.
Now that guy's going to admit an energy,
but you don't think there's Karma just
for like you'd do something bad and then
so something bad will happen.
I think a genuinely believe,
and this is no crystals in my pocket,
I genuinely believed that if you do
something that you know to be awful,
that that has an equal
effect coming back at you.
Like whatever bad that you've put out in
terms of like doing something evil to a
person, the way you feel
personally about yourself,
you will take an equal blow.
I really believe that.
And where does that blow come from?
I think comes from your
own introspective thinking.
I think maybe even worse. You know,
you might even feel worse than that.
Like you could say something rude to a
person just because you're tired and then
you realize you said something rude,
annoying. All right, why did I do that?
I didn't mean. And then they can be like
Tom, Papa's right now. I'm not really not.
I just, I'm so tired, you know, and you
just ask me something stupid. I'm sorry.
But it's like, it's hard to
turn that around, you know?
So you might hate yourself more
than they even get mad at you.
So Karma is really you
dealing with the energy.
It's not the universe saying now
something bad's going to happen to you.
You're kind of creating it with
your own actions and your own stuff.
I think it's real dangerous when we
pretend that we have any sort of real
understanding of the patterns of all
the events that take place in the world.
So when you start to say like someone,
something happened to someone
because of Karma, that's okay.
The problem was saying
that is what about babies?
What about babies with leukemia?
Where they bad babies? What happened?
Why did they get cancer?
Why did they die young?
Why did they die in car accidents? Why
the day? That doesn't make any sense.
They didn't never done anything bad there.
But that's where you could say that, uh,
you know, bad shit happens to us all,
but can you create more bad ship?
You find your balance possible
co two.
And it's,
it's also entirely possible that you're
creating more bad shit but feeling bad
about yourself because
you've done bad shit.
So you create more of this negative
energy that you carry around with you.
I think that's entirely possible too.
But I think that we also have this
weird need to define things, you know,
and that I think that we're,
we're looking to this thing that we're
calling Karma and we're saying that this
is like this,
this definite correlation between action
and reaction and between the good you
put out there and the
good that comes back.
And my take is that I think there's
definitely something going on,
but I don't think we should define it
yet cause I don't think we really know.
And I think as soon as we box it up and,
and say it's this thing and this is the,
the absolute reaction that the world
has when you put good out there,
good comes back. Good people die all
the time, folks. Good people die.
I think we're, I think that
there's, I think there is
an energy and the, you know,
we know it from the work that we do. I
think it's both. When you stand on stage,
there's an energy in that room,
that transference between you and the
people that are out there and you're
playing with it and it's a
real thing. It's a very real
thing. It's like hypnosis,
right? Yeah, yeah, yeah, it
is. And, and then they can,
they can reverse hip hypnotize you.
They can bring this other energy the
other way so that there is this energy of
all of us out there and running around.
It's,
it's not that far to think then there
couldn't be good energy and there's bad
energy and theirs.
And is that ultimately good and evil?
Maybe it is all generated
from human beings.
Maybe if you educated everyone and they
could all be kind and try and come at it
that way, we could actually
feel that there was more good.
But that's just more good coming
from people. I don't know. Well,
if you want to get really spacey
with this, Surely Really Spacey,
it's the holidays you go, okay, well what,
what exactly are people doing? That's
what you do. You, what are people doing?
What are they doing? Like what,
what's our purpose to be being here?
Look at us from an outside perspective.
Like pretend you're not a person, right?
You're looking at all the
people like what are they doing?
They're moving really fast.
They're spending most of their time
doing things they don't want to do and
they're buying stuff bustling around.
So because they're throwing
all this money at stuff,
the stuff keeps getting better.
So every year this stuff keeps getting
more complex and more capable and more
high tech and more space age. This
is bananas, man. I've got to watch,
I can call it people like fucking
Dick Tracy man, right? Yeah.
And that as people keep going on and on
and on and on with this stuff. This is,
we need some sort of energy behind this
innovation and a lot of the energies,
conflict, conflict and resolution,
conflict and resolution,
conflict and victory, victory and defeat.
And if it defeat makes you work harder.
And there's all these interacting forces
that are constantly moving together.
I'm with you, ended this,
a lot of it is expressed.
The success of this little game has
expressed in material possessions.
The success in this game is expressed in
Hamptons mansions and private jets and
Bentleys and Pam,
I'm winning this fucking crazy game off
stuff and there's a lot of value and
winning the crazy game.
Who Stopped?
So we let these people acquire all this
stuff and you've got all these diamonds
and fuck, yeah, this is,
this is forcing more stuff to be
made better and more innovation,
which will eventually,
and this is where it gets space
just of all waiting for this part.
This is going to be what people become.
People are going to become some
sort of symbiotic organism,
but something that's tied into electronics
and that this, it's happening now.
It's happening slowly and we're making
it with stuff and as we keep making,
it's eventually gonna get to a part that
was the thing you would like to do more
than anything is having to enhance
your experience on earth. Right.
I want to be able to take pictures. Yes,
yes. I want to be able to email people.
Yes, yes. Yeah. But I also want to, I want
it to make my experience on earth better.
Well then we're going to have to
integrate with your circuitry, Tom, papa,
and then live forever. Maybe. Maybe that's
what the organisms are trying to do.
They're trying to
get rid of the monkey that wants to
start the wars all the time. Right.
It's enlightenment. That urge that
none of our goofy ass system evil.
What if only some that would be a great
science fiction movie with this is the
future and they probably
were already made it.
But if only some people went on board
with the new enlightenment that you'd get
from these like headsets.
Like remember the dude from Star Trek,
the blind guy from sesame street.
Remember he was,
he used to be on sesame street,
right? Yeah. The, he was the uh,
the vibrating Rainbow Lavar yeah. Reading
Lavar Burton. Barbara, yeah. Yeah.
If we all had those things on, there was
only like 10 of them flooded. Know No,
like falling into those people bought
into it and those things completely cure
you of a, of any evil.
It just moving along.
I think that, uh, I don't
know. I mean there is,
maybe there is no purpose
to us being here, but it is.
So you got that shit for pep boys,
that's a filter.
That's a really cool air filter at the
top of the muscle car, isn't it? Yeah.